[Music]  my mother and I left to dream that we  are not alone in the whole universe that  the stars are the eyes of the angels  all the attention is focused on the  events in the south of Moscow I don't  mean to rush you or anything but it'll  be another 50  but identify flying objects detective  [Music]  we've waited thousands of years for  extraterrestrial contact the  metropolitan district and an  unidentified flying object fell onto  residential buildings  are we at war that depends on how they  react next what is this object the  weapon don't you think they came here  for we have no idea what the moral norms  of the aliens are why do we have to  explain it to the aliens why do we have  to disparage some kind of context  because this is a unique chance for all  of humanity  a real chance to understand something  about ourselves to know who we are we're  all going to die anyway  don't be scared  our main task is to keep any possibility  of Bothan conflict under control  [Music]